دعنا نقول ذلك
العبثية تقف في بعض النواحي أيضًا
مضحك وبالتالي بالفعل
خير ما فعلناه و
ما يجب ان نفعله
يصل في الانتخابات النهائية أوروبا
الدوري لا يزال نتيجة جيدة ولكن ليس
عليه أن يرضينا وعلينا الآن أن نفعل ذلك
الغوص في الدوري لأنه على أي حال
بالنظر إلى الترتيب ، الترتيب بدون
يجب أن تظل العلامات النجمية في العلامات الأولى
أربعة في آخر أربع مباريات
فزنا فقط عندما يكون هذا صحيحًا
أننا لعبنا الشروط أيضًا
العقلية حيث على أي حال
الاشتباكات المباشرة الالتزامات
بالطبع يجب أن تفوز لمحاولة ذلك
قص تلك الموجودة في المقدمة وهذا يجعلني
غاضب جدا لأنه غادر
نقاط للطريق وبعد ذلك سيكون لدينا
أيضًا كأس إيطاليا لذا دعنا نقول ذلك
مؤقتًا في صعوبة
الموسم لأنه ليس بسيطا
لقد كانت بسيطة وستكون أكثر
أصعب من الآن فصاعدا
دعنا نقول ترتيبًا جيدًا في
البطولة نحن في نهائي اوروبا
الدوري سويًا نهائي كأس إيطاليا